now and then happens a girl so full of
summertime that school boys go home and
say you know there's a new girl in our
class and she's my sweetheart of course
she doesn't know nothing about it but
she is and years later those school boys
are saying gosh I wish I had mentioned
it to her in Hollywood the nearest thing
to that is Miss Ann Blythe she will
present the award for the best
achievement by a studio sound Department
ladies and gentlemen miss Ann Blyth
hello Bob you know it might be a good
idea and to explain too that the sound
ward is one of the few which is never
given to an individual would you mind
clearing that up
not at all Bob so many people are
involved in the recording of a picture
mixers sound cutters all sorts of
technicians that no one person could be
singled out for the final result so the
award is given for the best achievement
by a studio sound Department and the
pictures which have been nominated are
Johnny Belinda Warner Brothers moonrise
Marshall grant pictures production
Republic the Snakepit 20th Century Fox
the Snakepit 20th century
you
thank you miss blye